let it be clear if you were born in 1995
onward you have only known a world that
has exoplanets so I will KN you that
Generation generation
exoplanet wow look at that I see what
you see what I did you see what I did
there right and by the way I'm going to
say if you were born from 1995 on you
don't know anything
Chuck you're you're a bunch of like
idiots okay and social media sucks all
right your generation is a
waste Vladimir bruta wants to know this
being the exoplanets are Out Of Reach
for at least many Millennia why is it
important to investigate them shouldn't
we focus on knowing more about our solar
system you never know how soon
somebody's going to invent a warp
drive it could happen next year year not
likely Next Century you want to you it's
cheap to find planets you're saying
let's focus on our own planet and on
exoplanets it's telescope time that's
cheap that's cheap exploring the solar
system is expensive because you got
actual space probes and even that is not
as expensive as so many other things
that we do in life do you realize going
to Saturn with Cassini costs less than
what Americans spend on lip balm in a
year that yearly budget for that mission
don't be telling me let's do this not
that let's do it all do you think we'll
find life on an exop planet in the next
hundred years Neil well I think yes
because there's a whole Cottage sub
industry of exoplanet research that
worries about
biomarkers these are things no you don't
see the life directly on the planetary
surface but you see their effect on the
atmosphere of the planet and
and you can't hide that so I think we
will know one way or another whether a
catalog of exoplanets uh where whether
any of them contain life any of them
looking at us they would see sort of
runaway Smog and greenhouse gases and
they that would tell them there's no
sign of intelligent life on
Earth where seeing the effect a planet
has on its Star as the planet moves in
front or trans it's its star so we're
we're seeing the planet move but only by
measuring how the Starlight changes okay
we're not seeing the planet directly so
how much can you tell from a dip in
light that's coming from a star I mean
it seems like a very limited amount of
information first of all from the Dip
the depth of the transit you can tell
how big the planet is that's pretty
obvious like if it's very deep then the
planet is Big compared to the star and
if it's shallow then it's tiny you can
also measure are the period you see how
frequently you see these transits in
front of the star and you can tell the
orbital period of the planet so these
are easy now the other things that are
sort of less trivia but you can also
tell how far the transit is off from the
center line of the star does the planet
go exactly along the line of side
crossing the star along its diameter or
it's like slightly upset or maybe it's
even grazing so you can tell this from
the shape of the transit I think that's
sort of a an interesting thing M and I
left out the most maybe most important
one um which is measuring the atmosphere
of the planet and the elements or
molecules in the atmosphere so what you
can do is you take a spectrum of the
star when the planet is not in front of
it so you take a spectrum you see the
star light split into wavelength and
from it's a very complicated spectrum
and from that you can figure out what
elements there are in the spectrum of
that star and then then you take another
one when the planet is blocking the star
and the star light is actually shining
through the atmosphere of the planet and
the planet atmosphere will be absorbing
some of the Starlight if you compare the
two the spectrum of the star without the
planet in front with the planet in front
you can tell what the atmosphere of the
planet is made of wow um and I think
that's you know you can tell okay there
is an atmosphere here which has water
molecules in it or it has sodium minut
it this have been or if it has oxygen
that'd be kind of interesting because
oxygen is not stable and so something
would be making that oxygen and then be
these are this would be your first
indication or at least your first hint
of life I guess yeah so that's why I
mentioned it because exactly the the the
best bet right now for what we call a
biomarker is Ozone and oxygen because if
there's no life replenishing these they
would basically oxidize a planet so
Planet would become big red and Rusty
instead of what it is um yeah and and in
this case in Earth's case it's the plant
life that's making the oxygen uh not
humans or any other animal life plus you
know in the first two billion years we
were not producing oxygen we were
producing mean so this is not saying
that if you see a planet with no oxygen
it has no life we can't say that yet
right exactly this one of one of our
best if it does have oxygen that's a
good bet if you're betting bet
I think the question also as what we
cannot discover from this um
and I mean the transit is such that
obviously what's on the on the dark side
of the planet facing towards us um we
don't see any details we can't resolve
the
planet the transit will not resolve
spatial features on this planet there
you go um where's a direct Imaging of
one the hope is one day we'll have
enough resolution to actually see oceans
or clouds or something on it yeah okay
yeah
yeah all of the detection techniques we
have so far and now even the
characterization techniques um they're
unable to resolve the surfaces of
planets we don't even see them as a
circle it's just a point of light in the
best case scenario you collect that
light maybe spread it out into a rainbow
and you look for all of these chemical
fingerprints that are in the light um
but that doesn't mean that we haven't
thought about what such a future looks
like um what technology would enable
resolving the surfaces of planets and
what we've come up with so far maybe the
future will hold surprises but so far
we're thinking about a a network of
what's called interferometers in space
well separated out kind of like the alma
array of uh submillimeter telescopes in
the desert they work in concert they
combine their light make use of the fact
that you can spread them out over great
distances which gives you very sharp
spatial resolution so maybe that's
something that we'll do in the future
what's behind that is of course the
bigger the telescope the more resolution
you have so if you have multiple
telescopes scattered across a landscape
they have an effective size that is the
distance between them right it's not
just one single lens and so that's
that's what Natalie's talking about
there and so yeah I look forward to that
hey if you enjoy stupid people as much
as I do and by that I mean laughing at
them then you need to pick up tickets to
the taping of my comedy special Chuck
Nice just smart enough it's happening
November 17th and 18th at the midnight
theater in Hudson yards New York City
tickets are available at Chuck comic.com
go get yours right now and listen I'm
only joking about the stupid people
thing I mean there's really no stupid
people there's just missing informed
people
right will there ever be a way to detect
exoplanets quickly without the need for
long periods of observation in other
words will there be a uh will there be a
uh kind of like quick and easy snap to
it like hey another exoplanet there we
go yeah yeah well might put Jason out of
a job Jason what do you
think well normally we have to wait for
to go all the way around the star so
whatever the planet's orbital period is
you want to have two or three of those
and so if it's a star if it's a planet
like the Earth that's going to take
something like 3 years but the other way
is if you have a really really good
camera something that can uh so so it
just take a picture of the planet and
then it's just point and click you point
you take a picture of the star Oh look
The Dot there that's the planet and if
you have the right kind of camera it can
tell you right away if it's the planet
or not now so that's the Dream It's
called cornography
and uh there are chronographs that exist
and and they look for a long time but if
they look at the right star in a matter
of minutes they know that they've found
something that looks like a planet right
next to it so yeah hopefully we'll at
some point get some space-based
coronagraphic telescopes that can just
point and click and find them pretty
quickly tically speaking it'll take a
while that that sounds like Tom Hanks
right uh what is it the right stuff
whatever Tom Hanks puts his thumb up and
blocks the Moon
right I mean that's sort of what you're
doing you're trying to block the light
from the Star CU that's drowning out the
light from the planet right that's right
you just want to hold a nickel in front
of in front of the star and see if you
can see the planet kind of thing and
it's a really hard problem people talk
about trying to you know find a firefly
next to a search light in New York but
you're doing it from Los Angeles or
something I mean it's a very difficult
technical problem and that's why that's
why we don't do it all the time right
now okay guess were you thinking about
life on the planet you're you're looking
yeah oh yeah yeah I I think it's a
fascinating topic um and um I think the
first U sort of written record of
someone contemplating about it is is
from ancient Greece but there's also
High hands in the um 18th century um
pondering about all the stars being Suns
and why not they have have planets and
why some planets actually are like the
Earth
and he actually writes in his there's a
work Cosmo Theos where he wres like and
there must be all these alien
civilizations on these planets and some
of them might be intelligent and looking
back at us I think he published his book
sort of to say post humus just to make
sure he's not burnt on some or
something speculating about life in the
universe yeah yeah if if if the universe
is divine because God created it and we
are the Divine creation of God you would
not expect to find life anywhere else
but Earth so this is quite heretical
yeah now we know that there are I would
the estimates vary over time because
we're refining it but this basically
about 20% of solar type stars have a
planet that's Rocky so it's not like a
helium or hydrogen giant it's Rocky like
Earth and is in what we call the
habitable zone so if you multiply the
400 billion stars in our galaxy you take
there's about 40 billion of them similar
to the Sun and you multiply that by 0.2
that's about 8 billion um Rocky
habitable planets just in our own Galaxy
I think it's an interesting thing if you
look up at the mway which is lost for
99% of Americans but if you actually
happen to go to one of the national
parks or travel far you look up at the
Milky Way what's the probability of
someone looking back at you I think
that's a fun question which we don't
know the answer to yet that's a little
creepy though
but but but goar we left out a part of
that question which was what percent
might be orbiting a a binary star oh I
see yes that was indeed um part of the
question so um first of all just to give
a tiny introduction we actually did not
know that there are stable planets
around binary Stars so meaning there's a
two stars orbiting each other very close
in and there's a planet far out orbiting
this B Star it was only in Star Wars
twiin is the only one but then yeah
Kepler space telescope discovered 16 of
them or something like that so now we
know they exist and we also know that
some might be in what we call the
habitable zone so the probability is is
also exist but these planets are much
less frequent than the ones we that
around normal Stars so right so I guess
the the point there that you imply is
that if that planet were orbiting closer
to the binary star the orbit would
become less stable because it would get
really close to one star and then far
from the both but if you're far enough
away way it just sees kind of one
average gravity field is that a fair way
to describe it that's a fair way of
describing it and if it's very far away
it feels one gravity field but it does
not feel heat anymore so you get
freezing slow okay you want to be in in
in the right place um so for a binary
star that's somewhat more limited and I
don't have an an exact number I don't
think anyone does but we're closing in
on that number by first of all knowing
the frequency of planets around binary
stars or getting a handle on it and and
in the future I think we will soon learn
about what fraction of them are in this
habitable zone what and and I'll just
add that most of the Stars you see in
the night sky are multiple Planet double
and multiple Planet systems so so it's
it's not a question about a rare
possibility right it's it's um binary
star systems are not rare in the night
sky so it's a very natural question to
wonder whether they could also be
repositories of Planet 70% of stars are
in binaries inde and I have to add that
there's another solution when the two
stars are very far from each other
orbiting in say thousands of years or
tens of thousands of years and both of
them host planets very close in that's a
the opposite of the other one right
orbiting far from the pair and a pair is
orbiting far from each other so they
carry their own solar systems around
them cells an unstable planet can either
fall into the host star or get kicked
out so that the orbit does not maintain
itself around the host star yeah those
are the two solutions and curiously we
see the effect of both um the planets
that fell in the star they pollute the
star so you can detect elements due to
to planets that fell in in the
atmosphere of stars and the planets that
were kicked out that's really amazing I
think but they were detected through
what we call micr lensing they are dark
we don't see them but they go in front
of roughly in front of a star and they
lens the light of the star due to their
gravity and then you see the background
start brightening up and with this thing
over a decade or two they actually
measure that there are roughly about 40
billion free floating planets in our
galaxy like one tenth the number of the
stars of Vagabond planets yeah they have
no stars so if you know you're a
some weird
civilization that somehow developed on
such a planet because they have say
radioactive heat coming from the planet
they would actually have a very
different view of the universe like they
don't have a central Star right they
will at one point might discovered there
are even planets orbiting
[Music]
Stars